hi i just came home and read
a lot of messages that were not happy
with my latest
instagram post that was a tick-tock
video
candace cameron beret says she's sorry
after her latest tick-tock video
didn't exactly sit well with some of her
fans
and i usually don't apologize for these
things but
a lot of you thought it was weird and
i'm sorry
that was not my intention it all started
when the fuller house
star posted this tick tock video to her
instagram
[Music]
baby i'm a gangster too and it takes to
detangle
you don't wanna dance with me dance with
me honey i'm in love with you
that's candace dancing to lana del rey's
track
jealous girl holding up her bible with
the caption quote when they don't know
the power of the holy spirit
on the screen
[Music]
well some fans didn't like it and hit up
the comments to let her know that they
thought she was being too seductive
so the 45 year old mom of three removed
the clip from her insta and hit up her
story to explain
so many of you thought that i was trying
to be seductive
which clearly means i'm not a very good
actress because i was trying to be
strong not sexy
candice who didn't remove the clip from
tiktok
revealed that she got the idea from her
22 year old daughter natasha
who posted a different version of the
clip to her own tiktok account
referencing her former nhl star dad
valerie beret
[Music]
baby
[Music]
candace has always been candid with her
thoughts and
regularly shares them on social media
back in november
the actress opened up about her sex life
something she's received backlash for in
the past
here's what she told et about the mixed
reaction from fans
i've always been an open person when it
comes to all that stuff and i think but
i've never
publicly said it but all my friends know
that and my kids know that and obviously
my husband knows that
how do the kids feel when mom is so open
talking about sex then all that
comes with it i think they're i mean
they're pretty fine with it
until i say something that embarrasses
them which is
well it's always gonna happen but my
kids were even like mom why did you pop
up on daily mail
mom why did you pop up on this and like
talk why are you and i'm like i'm so
sorry honey i'm sorry
sometimes i just say things and and
i don't mean it for it to become a
headline and my son was like oh no it's
great
like okay good
you